tous les lundis matins dès le mois de
janvier les élèves de l'école paul
langevin avec un nouveau cours au
programme pour les plus grandes
c'était juste après la récréation à 10
heures aujourd'hui est lourd parce que
on est des francas
j'aimerais qu'on travaille le khalife
les enfants avaient aussi un nouveau
professeur guillaume lavoie avec ce
jeune chef de choeur médiateur culturel
à l'opéra de lille ont ils font leurs
premiers pas dans le monde de l'art
lyrique
alors cette semaine vous avez que des
écouteurs classe d'un nouveau champ est
normalement vous le connaissez par coeur
ben alors c'est parti partis sont
étirées d'un opéra composé spécialement
pour les élèves de primaire mais pas
vraiment ce que ces enfants ont
l'habitude d'écouter au quotidien pas du
tout cela du tout non mais qu'est ce qui
te plaît quand même et surtout dans ce
que vous êtes en train de préparer ce qu
on exprime des émotions et enfin c'est
comme si on parlait au public en fait ça
ce sera pour plus tard quand ils se
produiront sur scène d'ici là il y a
encore du travail pour les apprentis
chanteurs bien restez pas se mélanger
avec les jeux cours avec les autres
groupes chanter en canon score c'était
difficile moi je me suis vite aperçu que
je pouvais avoir un niveau d'exigence
assez haut
parce que ils ont besoin de ça aussi bas
pour chanter pour s'engager
et même si des fois je suis vraiment
exigeant avec eux je leur fais reprendre
plusieurs fois certains passages où des
petits détails
eh bien je vois qu après ils sont
vraiment heureux d'aller vers ce
résultat là parce qu'ils savent que
c'est vers là qu'on va et voilà c'est
par là qu'on va faire un beau spectacle
on entend que vous arrivez aussi à
chanter avec vos oreilles parce que
quand je joue un piano à chaque fois le
premier temps est bien respectée donc ça
c'est vraiment beaucoup mieux
entre deux répétitions avec guillaume
les élèves découvrent aussi les
coulisses de l'opéra
petit détour ce jour là dans l'atelier
décors et costumes
là où il ya les costumes d'enfants
ces costumes ont tous été créés par les
couturiers de l'opéra alors forcément en
les voyant travailler les enfants
pensent déjà à leur spectacle et
s'interroge on va emporter nous alors
vous quel rôle vous allez jouer pendant
votre spectacle est bien exactement vous
allez être habillé en écolier donc vous
allez être habillé comme tous les jours
une petite déception dans les rangs
avant de découvrir impressionné le
travail des menuisiers voir qu'il ya
autant de choses qui se passent derrière
justin à l'opéra qui va durer qui dure
trois heures bah c'est quand même bien
moi des fois la nuit cambrai va le voir
comment ça peut faire comment j'arrive à
imaginer comment les scènes ça peut se
passer
et plus les enfants n'apprennent
individus ils sont curieux pour faire
les décors alors pour l'instant ils sont
pas encore en construction au des cas et
ils vont être assez simple
le gros du dkr va être sur des rideaux
qui vont être projetés pour en savoir
plus il faudra poser la question aux
metteurs en scène et ça tombe bien la
première séance de travail avec lui se
profile déjà